well suppose to doctors is better than
one here we go
properly kicking off series hungry of
Doctor Who overdue Doctor Who review and
the introduction of Martha Jones not the
introduction of prima German because she
was in doomsday and the army of ghosts
character who's now dead and gets a
one-off mention here so this I have I've
maintained in the past that this is one
of the better new companion episodes and
having Maori watched it I stand by that
I do think it is one of the better new
companion episodes you know introducing
a companion for the first time or you
know getting them lined up to fill that
role and so I do still feel that but at
the same time it has most of the faults
that the majority of these stories tend
to have but it's also got pretty
consistent strengths and it nails what
it needs to nail so let's start with the
good stuff so pre management as Martha
Jones I'm probably butchering her last
name I think but I should have looked up
how to pronounce that properly I'll just
keep referring to her as Martha so
Martha gets an intro and Martha is a
strong character pretty much right off
the bat you can see that you know she's
not a prodigy she's not excessively you
know over-the-top intelligent but she
can keep her wits about her she can put
two and two together she can ask the
right questions and you can immediately
see see why that would appeal to
like the doctor and their dynamic off
the bat is also pretty good and like
that is the main thing that this nails
it nails the feeling of why the doctor
would gravitate towards her especially
fairly soon after having lost rose and
it is kind of funny that he you know
he'll spend a good chunk of this series
sort of saying you know you're not
replaced actually says that in this one
you're not replacing her he's very
emphatic about this so you know to do
the to do the relationship metaphor
which normally I don't like to do good I
don't like the thought of the end of the
doctor and a romantic relationship but
that's very much what this is modeled on
so we'll go with it this is the the
rebound
you know after losing what you thought
was the love of your life this is the
rebound relationship that and that you
get into when you know you're not
actually ready to start a new
relationship but something feels right
so you move forward even though at every
step of the way you're going yet no this
is this is not I'm still like I'm not
getting with new I know but the the
result is that he's not taking that he's
not gonna take full advantage of the
bond that he has with her and that he's
gonna kind of leave her hanging but
that's me getting ahead of myself and
looking at the future stuff the two of
them bounce off each other very well
they have a good dynamic and like I said
you totally get why the doctor is like
oh I like you Martha Jones ah the Judoon
I actually like the Judoon I mean the
designs ridiculous it's big giant rhinos
they don't bother me as much as say the
cat nurses from New Earth does and for
what I admit is a pretty superficial
reason which is that I can tell how much
work went into these heads like not that
the cat makeups were unimpressive but it
you know it was just it was cat makeup
I'd seen that kind of cat makeup before
I hadn't seen a bipedal rhinoceros
police officer thing before so like even
though the you know just basing
something off an animal does tend to bug
me just a little bit here probably bugs
me the least here of any time that it's
happened on Doctor Who and I like you
know kind of they're they're simplistic
very straightforward way of going about
it yet at the same time there's
obviously a certain amount of cunning at
least at some level of the Judoon
and I feel like that's something that
that gets hinted at here but we know we
have never gotten to see properly which
is that okay yeah they're described just
kind of thugs and and whatnot but you
know the idea of yanking the entire
Hospital off the planet to put it where
you have jurisdiction that I mean that
simple but effective it also takes a
little bit of planning so it doesn't
want to make me wonder where in the
hierarchy of the Judoon is the thought
process going I mean later on will meet
the shadow Proclamation and you assume
that it's them but I do actually like
the jejune I think they work pretty well
I think overall the episode is well
paced it's a lot of fun its main area
which it suffers and like I said
basically every new companion episode
suffers from this and that's a villain
problem the villain is not especially
threatening is not particularly well
developed and in a way there isn't a ton
you can actually do about that because
when you're introducing a new companion
that needs to be the focus you we need
to get to know this person we need to
get to know their dynamic with the
doctor that is where the focus has to be
so the villain is ultimately going to
end up being disposable that having been
said the plasma for with her little
straw that she sticks in people's necks
to suck their blood that even by even by
sort of the the sliding scale of yeah it
doesn't need to be a great villain
that's still pretty silly and there's
also there's some I think this might
mark the first like or at least to me
really notable instance
of the doctor recovering from something
with just weird bizarre control over his
body like he absorbs a ton of radiation
and forces it down into his foot and
then into his shoe okay so why didn't he
dump the radiation from the end of time
part two into his shoe now I'm not good
see I'm just bringing that up because it
did I did sort of think of it this time
but I don't want to dwell on that
because that's the kind of plot hole
that I don't like to devote my time to
they they don't really bug me that much
but I know other people notice them so
yeah there's moments like that and I
also don't like that the doctor kisses
Martha I know he has his whole big
insistence that is just a biomatter
transference or whatever it is basically
just leaving a trace of his lips on her
so that it stalls the the Judoon and
like it fits again within the whole
rebound relationship metaphor that he
basically leads her on way hard right
off the bat even and even though he's
insisting he didn't mean it like your
words say one thing your actions say
another yeah there's gonna be a
disconnect you're gonna have to deal
with that so I mean it fits the
matically but again it just hits that
button that I don't like doctor and
companion romantic I don't like it I
don't like it I never will
I'm not sure there's too much else to
really sort of dig into those are kind
of the the four major elements there's
the doctor there's Martha there's the
Judoon there's the plasma for and really
the only one of those that I don't think
works particularly well is the plasma
floor and then the rest work to varying
degrees so there will be specific
homeless that are a little off specific
moments that are pretty good I like that
that after it's all done and this doctor
who had just like been
of following the jejune around like just
tell us what to do so you don't hurt us
like is giving a TV interview when they
all get back to earth going I told them
you can't do this I'm like yep that's
yeah that's exactly what would happen
after the fact whoever survived gets to
make their own legend I love this stuff
so there for the little touches that I
complain about their other little
touches that I like so the the list of
things that don't work or could have
been better is actually fairly short and
the list of things that work is just
larger now it's I don't think aside from
the introduction of Martha that this is
a particularly impactful episode it's
you know there is nothing aside from
Martha feels particularly significant it
has the feel of a fluff of a of a lark
of just a fun little time episode and
there's nothing wrong with those but
they do tend to be considered some of
the more disposable ones but again if
you're gonna compare it to other
episodes that introduced new companions
for the first time so like for
comparison that would be things like
Rose I'm going to count partners in well
you could either count it as partners in
crime or the runaway bride I think the
eleventh hour is probably the best of
this kind of thing so that I mean that
one is really good but then there's the
bells of st. John and die and the pilot
and I just the the the companion
introduction episodes are rarely great
and I think this is a good rollicking
time it keeps the pace up it knows how
to it knows that it can't slow down
because of it slows down too much you'll
realize how ridiculous this one is and
it is ridiculous but it's ridiculous in
a fun way so that's my thoughts on Smith
and Jones have you seen it lately what
are your thoughts about it whatever they
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about a whole bunch of stuff
to do buttons links patreon P o box
other wings to check out besides all in
the description give them a look give
them a click or if you don't that's okay
too because at the
the day you're the council i'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
should have done this before I started
recording impromptu Windsor knot
tutorial or would be if I was explaining
this instead of just doing it but you
know what can you do here we go and that
is not my best but it'll do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]